I am the benefits delivery and
decision transformation manager
for the California
Department of Transportation.
Previously, I was the
data science manager
for the City of Los Angeles, as
well as at the Center for Data Science
and Public Policy at the
University of Chicago.
Mostly about data,
tacos, Los Angeles.
Sunset sunset.
Photos some architecture.
All fun times.
So here's the existential
panic that wakes me up
in the morning.
50% of greenhouse gas
emissions in California
are currently caused
by transportation.
Your state might be slightly
different or country,
but it's going to be
in the same ballpark.
If you've been paying
attention to the GHG world
at all over the last decade
and climate change and whatnot,
you will know there's
this big transition.
That was not true in 2010.
In 2010, the biggest
emitter in California
was power generation.
That sector is very
quickly decarbonizing.
You can thank wind and
solar being really cheap.
So you're like, great Hunter
buy everybody in electric car.
We got this solved, right?
And the answer is you are wrong.
I apologize.
But if you look at the
lifetime total carbon emissions
of transportation, electric
cars are only about 50% better.
And maybe, if heavy
industry becomes greener,
maybe they'll be
about 75% better
than conventional
gasoline driven cars.
Totally fine.
This happens.
We have a plan
for this, which is
we have a net zero by
2050 plan in California.
The idea is California needs
to have a massive reduction
in something called VMT,
which you hear thrown around
in those stories.
It stands for vehicles, miles
traveled. Transportation world,
much like technology world,
filled with acronyms.
I'm going to try to only
use the tech acronyms today.
So that gets us there.
And then so California,
we wrote all these plans
and we established that we have
to double our transit mode
share in California by 2030 and
then we need to 5 exit by 2050.
And you're like, great,
how do I take the bus?
So looking at this, I was
actually going to ask,
show of hands who like
regularly takes public transit?
This is more than a lot
of talks I've given.
Who takes public
transit and pays cash?
Okay. Who has like some
sort of weird, smart card
that they have to load?
OK, mostly smart
card users. Who gets
to just use normal
people money like you
would go to a coffee shop?
All right.
Who who takes an agency that is,
like, super tiny? Like anybody
take Dial a Ride?
OK so long story short,
California, you might think,
is only three or four
transit agencies.
You got LA Metro, you got BART.
There are over 800 transit
agencies with over 200 agencies
offering fixed route
service in the bus.
So when you think
about California,
Cal-ITP was founded
to answer this challenge,
which is I want to go from
Santa Monica to Sacramento
or wherever, and I want to be
able to seamlessly plan, pay
for and execute my trip.
We want to unify
transit in California
with a common fare
payment system.
So you're not like
juggling all those cards.
Anybody who got a smart trip
card for DC just for the week
can deal with that.
Make sure that you have real
time data on where is the bus,
and then make sure it's
seamless to get verification
of discounts and whatnot.
I'm going to try to present
now that it is not as loading
and we're going to
see if this works.
Come on.
Yes there we go.
And all right.
He does not like me at all.
So we're just going to
keep going this way.
So the things that we really
do to make transit seamless
and I promise I'm going
to get to the R stuff
soon, unify the
customer experience,
make sure that we
are prioritizing
sustainable modes
of transportation
and grounded in equity first.
So how do you think
about a transit trip?
There are three, three
parts of the trip, right?
So the first thing
is, can I plan and get
to the bus or the train on time?
The next thing is,
once I get there,
can I pay for it successfully?
And then third in
the United states,
we have a ton of different
types of transit discounts
and benefits.
You might be a senior,
you might be a student,
your employer might
pay for your trips.
There's all sorts of things.
If you think about
California, it is big.
There are tons of
like legacy systems
that you have to
go interface with.
So we have a philosophy of
like transit technology needs
to be like LEGOs.
You can snap your fare payment
system into your real time
passenger information system,
into your benefit system,
into all your different cad,
AVL subsystems and whatnot.
We call a lot of this work on
the data front mobility service
data, which is all
about providing.
So now we're going to
wonk out on trip planning,
providing accurate and complete
information for trip planning.
So, when you think like what
is the vision for that?
It's that you have a
complete and accurate picture
of what is going on at
any of those 800 agencies
in California.
And then when I
pull up my phone,
whether I'm in Humboldt County
in the far North of California,
or Imperial County, down down
near the US-Mexico border,
I could find where
is any bus, where
is any train, what are
my transfers, how much I
am I going to pay
in fare? It should easily
show up on Google Maps.
So the way we do this is we
establish clear expectations.
We assess every
agency in the state
using automated technologies
to say, how well are you
doing this?
And then we provide
technical assistance
to go meet those goals.
So what is the clear
expectation for California?
For those of you who
are transit nerds,
you may have heard something
called the General Transit Feed
Specification, formerly
the Google Transit Feed
Specification.
This is the thing that
means Google Maps,
Apple Maps, Citymapper, transit,
your R applications can see
bus locations and bus schedules
in both real time and schedules.
And then on the back
end side, we also
have a set of interoperability
principles for the vendors
that piece together these
different pieces of information
to work together.
Assessing progress.
This is what's really fun.
We take a look at
all this data and we
produce in-depth assessments
for each agency being like,
oh, you know, you didn't
have trip information for 33%
of your buses in the last year
in real time.
Something like that.
We talk to them every year
doing like a collaborative list
of stuff.
We produce monthly public
reports on public transit data
quality and public
transit quality.
How how many jobs
are agencies serving?
How many folks are doing?
And we do this for every
one of the agencies
in the state that provides
fixed route bus service
now. And then we do
night light and we
monitor this all
nightly to make sure
that when things break,
for example, right now
school year is ending, a
lot of transit agencies
are changing service.
A lot of the smaller agencies
are not telling Google that
that service is changing, which
means if you show up to the bus
and they're using an old
version of their schedule,
you're going to miss your bus.
So we really try to make
sure that stays on top.
And then finally, we do a
lot of technical assistance
work across our whole program.
We have a transit data
help desk, you know,
which has been really focused
on getting demand-responsive
transit into GTFS.
That's stuff like Dial a
Ride, paratransit, whatnot.
We've built open source
hardware and software
to produce GTFS real time to
help agents, small agencies
in rural areas to
go do it who can't
afford more complex systems.
We've produced playbooks and
documented transit stacks
for different agencies, and we
do interoperable development
work.
All right, so magic universe,
we've done all this work.
You've now shown
up, the bus is here.
What's about to happen?
We need a new way
to pay for transit.
So, you know, from what we say,
paying for transit should be
as easy as paying for coffee.
Customers can instantly pay.
Tap their bank
card, their Apple
pay, Google pay, their
mobile wallet and whatnot.
In order to do this, you need
three pieces of technology.
One is called a fare validator.
Second thing is called a
fare calculation software.
Third thing is called
a payment processor.
This is tied to the.
One of the things
I love about Cal-ITP
is we hate inventing
stuff, so we really
try to leverage
global standards.
So this is how the
banking system works.
I did not know
anything about how
banks worked before
I started this job,
and now I know perhaps a
little bit too much so.
But rather than try to invent
our own custom flavor of how
to cards, how do we take money?
Do we need to set up
TVMs or retail networks?
We just said, how
can we make sure
that banks and standard credit
and debit cards can work?
So those three pieces of
technology that I mentioned
are over here and they talk
between the providers bank.
So this is the
state of California
has banking
relationships and those
go talk to Mastercard
Visa it talks
to your customers
bank all of this
happens basically magically.
This is called the
CEMV standard which
stands for Contactless,
Euro pay, Mastercard, Visa
and any transit agency in
the country can buy this.
We've done standardized
procurement.
Anybody who's a
government person
knows procurement is the
worst thing about government.
Absolutely maybe hiring
is worse, but pretty bad.
So we have what we call
the mobility marketplace
for purchasing these
types of solutions.
And it's pre-negotiated
it's like a bench contract,
really easy.
And then on a data side,
what my team can do
is because that data
is standardized,
the types of outputs
you get from CEMV banks
all have been they've
documented this.
Yes, you have to transmit
all the data over SFTP,
but it is standardized.
It comes in every day.
We can build merchant services
for these transit agencies that
helps them understand their
revenue per day, what type
of fares they're getting.
Are people paying with cards
or digital wallets more often?
And that's really focused on
the transit agency's needs.
Joining that data
with their GTFS data
upstream to say like
this route is doing
more rides, whatnot
in their. Flip side
of the problem in America,
I'll talk about
this very quickly,
but we need to make sure that
we cover the un and under-banked.
We work with different
issuing partners.
It's really kind of crazy,
but it's much easier
to get accounts.
This is sort of grounded
in our equity goal.
I could talk for a much
longer time about this,
but I'm going to kind
of speed through.
I'm also going to speed through
this that discount enrollments,
you want to standardize
and simplify.
We have a web application.
If this was a web
conference, I would
talk about how we do all this
non PII linking of people's
identities to stuff.
This is what it looks
like in practice.
This is the
Sacramento light rail.
You don't need a special card.
You can just go and tap your
credit and debit card.
It works really easily.
You get fare capping.
So this is like the
fun data nerdery part.
We have 800 transit
agencies we're stewarding,
like that is too many
to manage ETL processes
for each of those agencies.
So what we focus on is what we
call our core data sets, which
is we use these three data
standards to really drive
our analytics processes.
So GTFS schedule, we
do that every night.
We do all sorts of different
output analysis from that data.
GTFS real time, again, this
is just, where is the bus
and when is it going
to show up at stop.
We get that data
every 20 seconds.
This is sort of actually gets
to be big data because you start
talking about the bus location
of every bus in California,
every 20 seconds.
You can do that to do level of
delay analysis, speed analysis.
Where should how
can you optimize
where to place potential
infrastructure investments?
And then finally,
our third standard
EMV payments two days
after the transaction
is when it comes through.
And that powers both
our payments dashboard
and a lot of traditional
reporting type
work if you're familiar
with the National Transit
Database and stuff.
So how do we do this? Again,
standard standards simplify,
share your resources.
So for batch processing and data
warehousing and share, compute,
we have a Airflow,
Kubernetes and BigQuery
sort of base stacked.
All of our code and
documentation is open source.
So I encourage you
to go peruse it.
Let's see, do I have
the doc site open here?
I do not have it
open here right now.
When it comes to
analysis, we tend
to do we have a JupyterHub.
We've been pretty
heavy users of siuba
on top of BigQuery, which
is the dplyr port for Python.
I highly recommend
checking it out,
especially if you're there.
And then finally, for
reporting and presentation,
haven't adopted
cartridges yet, but we
use things put
together all these sort
of different reports,
some of which
are more lightweight
but even more complex.
This is a whole website
that is generated out
of a Jupyter Notebook using
siuba to give you GTFS quality
reports for all these agencies.
So again, web is a little
slow, but you can see.
Let's pick on big blue bus.
That's Santa Monica, California.
And you get all this
sort of information.
And what's really cool
about this is do not need a.
Analysts who had a web
user to speak about.
This is entirely generated
out of a Python notebook
that is linked in there.
You can continue.
This is just some of the
elements you get in schedule.
You get some.
You can do these
statewide analysis
phase of what is a high
quality transit corridor.
Again, this is looking
at all of Los Angeles.
This is something
the state did not do.
And the reason we
were able to do this.
And if you take one
takeaway from this talk,
it's the data
standards, especially
if you work in a
distributed environment,
are your best friend.
And even if they're
not perfect data,
the exactly the right data.
When you start talking about
GTFS RT, kind of digging in,
there's trip updates,
vehicle positions,
which is exactly what
they say they are.
Again, we kind of do
this over and over again.
So you can see here are live
or were live screenshotted bus
speeds for Los Angeles,
Modesto and Oakland.
Suffice to say, there's
a lot of traffic,
but this has really been
transformative in how Cal-Trans
does its investments because
we can really now focus in
on this challenge of bus speeds,
which is that some more fun.
Here's a fun chart
of speed variability
for an individual bus route.
You can see that, you know,
in between certain stop payer
combinations,
buses have averaged
as low as 10 miles an hour.
And as high as 35
miles an hour, which
is definitely-- the traffic
engineers have their
work cut out for them.
And you can use it for,
like evaluation of like,
OK, here's exactly where
you need to drill down
and you can go from this
big, big global Google Maps,
Apple maps view down
to Route 44 Westbound
in the afternoon peak is 5.5
miles an hour on this one thing,
and we do it for every
agency in the state.
So all of this is
public and online.
I think I have the
analysis site pulled up
so you can go browse
these speed maps.
We publish this at
our analysis site.
All of these are
linked in the chat.
Here's Sacramento again.
You can kind of drill in all
just static, static maps, which
I love because we
have no hosting stuff
and that is Cal ITP.
That is like using
data to really drive
transformative transformation,
investment and operations.
I'll take any questions
you might have.
I realize I rushed
through a lot of that.